Landing under gunfire this was a
military operation that ended in
bloodshed
pre-dawn raid a video Guzman son of the
infamous Mexican drugs Boss El Chapo was
captured in the Northwest city of
culiacan
sparked widespread violence
the Sinaloa cartel allegedly led by
Guzman responded roadblocks vehicle
fires and fierce fighting left ten
soldiers and 19 suspected cartel members
dead
[Music]
even civilian passengers at the city's
airport cowered after reportedly being
shot at
Los Angeles
High number of criminal cells grouped
together to rescue a video end they
attacked members of the Army on site
seven members of the army were killed
and nine were injured
the arrest following six months of
police surveillance turned the streets
of this city into a battlefield
first of all regarding the case of a
video there is a request of provisional
detention for purposes of extradition we
think that the extradition will happen
in between four and six weeks from now
from the United States which presented
the extradition request
it is not the first time Guzman has been
arrested in 2019 he was taken into
custody only to be released after
further violence erupted
one year ago authorities in the U.S put
a 5 million reward up for information
leading to his arrest
[Laughter]
his capture is a rare victory for
officials in Mexico against this
powerful cartel with convenient timing
U.S President Joe Biden arrives in the
country next week for a Leader's Summit
with drug trafficking into the U.S on
the agenda
this latest single arrest is unlikely to
stop that flow anytime soon
down Whitehead Sky News